LIKE, YOU NEED TO FOCUS
ON WHAT YOU WANT.
THIS IS ABOUT YOU.
LIKE, WHAT DO YOU WANT?
- I MEAN, WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR EXACTLY?
- LIKE, I JUST FEEL
LIKE HE LOOKS
LIKE HIS FACE IS VERY FROWNY.
- MM-HMM.
YEAH, WE'LL--
WE'LL TAKE CARE OF THAT.
HE'LL BE VERY HAPPY
WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH HIM.
- DR. ARMOND IS AN AMAZING
PLASTIC SURGEON FOR DOGS.
- NOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE'RE GONNA MAKE THE FACE
A LOT MORE SYMMETRICAL.
- 'CAUSE I HATE
HOW HE LOOKS NOW.
- MM-HMM.
- YOU SPEAK TO HIM
AND HE LISTENS TO YOU,
AND THEN HE DOES
THE OPERATION.
- WE'LL SNIP OUT THE...
- OH, YEAH.
IT'S LIKE I DON'T WANT
SOMETHING IN MY HOME
THAT'S, LIKE,
UGLY BECAUSE--
- YOU WOULDN'T BUY AN UGLY SOFA.
- NO.
AND, LIKE, YOU WOULDN'T
TALK TO AN UGLY PERSON.
- NO, I DON'T.
I-I ONLY HIRE
VERY ATTRACTIVE PEOPLE,
AND MY THIRD WIFE
IS ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN THAT I KNOW.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.